من كسل ينضم اليه الان جري من هو مدير
الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
في السودان سيد اهلا وسهلا بك اي تقييم
يمكن اعطائه للاوضاع الانسانيه والحياتيه
في السودان مع دخول المواجهات الاسبوع
الثالث تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم سيد
جيرمن
تقييمنا عملا الى جانب الهلال الاحمر
السوداني وعندما نتحدث عن الاوضاع
الانسانيه فان الوضع سيء جدا
وهنالك
كوارث كبيره جدا والاولويه القصوى بالنسبه
لنا هي القطعه الصحيه
المستشفيات
الى الان ليس لديها الكهرباء او المياه
وغير قادره على العمل
فهم بحاجه الى مساعداته كبيره جدا وعلينا
ان نبدا بتقديم الدعم للمستشفيات خاصه من
خلال توفير المياه والكهرباء وكذلك توفير
اللقاحات طيب ما الذي يمكنكم تقديمه في
هذا الاطار يعني ان البحث عن الاحتياجات
ولكن هل يمكنكم تقديم اي مساعده في هذا
الاطار سيد جيرمن ام لا يعني لا يمكن
تقديمها في هذه الاوقات او لا يمكن ارسال
هذه المساعدات حتى لو توفرت
الاحد
جاءتنا الشحنه وصلت الى السودان
وهذه هي اول الشحنه من المواد الطبيه
المؤقته للارواح والان بدانا
بالعمل اللي يندق لها من السودان الى
الخرطوم ودارفور والمدن المتاثره بالقتال
هذه هي الشحنه الاولى كما اتوقع الشحنه
ثانيه في الايام المقبله
وكذلك ان نترقب وصول الافراد لتقديمي
المساعده في استجابتنا هنا في السودان
الان نحن
تقريبا وصلنا الى الوضع الذي يمكننا من
التزويد المستشفيات بالمساعدات الطبيه
وكذلك المتطوعين من الهلال الاحمر
السودانيه الذين يقدمون المساعده للجرحى
والمصابين ولكننا بحاجه الى ضمانات امنيه
من الاطراف المتقاتله الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لكي
اتمكن موظفون وقوافلنا من الانتقال او
الوصول الى المناطق المتاثره بالقتال
لتزويد تلك المعدات الطبيه الى المستشفيات
سيد جري من
ماذا تصل الى
من هنالك من يتولى توزيعها وما الضامن بان
الاطراف المتنازعه لن تسيطر على هذه
المساعدات لمصالحها
الصليب الاحمر سيكون مسؤولا عن توزيع هذه
المواد الى المستشفيات
وهذا المستشفيات هي المسؤوله عن توفير
عنايه الصحيه فمسؤوليه
كل هذا العمل سيبقى بين يدي اللجنه
الدوليه الى الصليب الاحمر ولكن من اجل
البدي بتنديد وتطبيقات العمل فنحن بحاجه
الى ضمانات امنيه من الاطراف
المتقاتله سبق وان
اخبرناهم
وطلبنا منهم تسهيل
عمل المنظمات الانسانيه والكوادر الطبيه
ونعمل من انهم سيسهلون عملنا لكي نتمكن من
تقديم المساعدات الى كل من هم بحاجه اليها
سي
جرب ايات السودان تحديدا مستشفيات
الخرطومه بشكل عاجل
العديد من المستشفيات في الخرطوم واغلبها
اليوم لا تعمل ولاسباب مختلفه السبب الاول
هو الافتقار الى الادويه كما ذكرت
والمعدات الطبيه
كما ان العديد من المستشفيات ليس لديها
المياه او الكهرباء كما هو الحال في
المناطق العديد من الخرطوم
والسبب الرئيسي لان محطات المياه
والكهرباء والبنى التحتيه المسؤوله عن
توفير المياه والكهرباء في المدن
هي بحاجه الى الصيانه والمسؤولون عن
صيانتها غادروا الخرطوم والبعض من هم
غير قادر على الذهاب من المنزل الى اماكن
العمل فهم ايضا بحاجه الى ضمانات امنيه
لكي يتناقلوا بحريه وامان داخل المدن من
اجل القيام باعمالهم
لانهم لم يقوم بها اعمالهم ولم تكن هناك
صيانه لشبكات المياه والكهرباء وهذه البنت
تحتيه ففي الختام المدينه سوف تفتقر الى
المياه والكهرباء هكذا هو الحال مع
المستشفيات
وحتى الكوادر الطبيه هم ايضا بحاجه الى
التحرك والانتقال منازلهم ذهابا الى
المستشفيات الاقنامي بعملهم والعوده الى
منازلهم فهم ايضا بحاجه لضمانات امنيه
كما ترون فهم المهم جدا للاطراف المقاتله
ان تساعد على تسهيل الحركه الامنه للفرق
الطبيه في الخرطوم وكافه المدن المتاثره
بالقتال
من اكثر من منظمه انسانيه حذرت او التخوفت
من امكانيه انتشار الكوليرا والملاريا هل
لديكم نفس هذه المخاوف وهل سجلت اي حالات
وفق متابعتكم
الى الان لم تردنا اي معلومات عن اي
اصابات
الخرطوم والمدن الاخرى ولكن التخوف هو ان
مثل هذه الاوبوياء قد تظهر وتبرز في
الايام المقبله اذا لم نقم بعملنا
لان السكان هنا ليس لدي امكانيه الحصول
على المياه النقيه او الصالحه للشرب فمثل
هذه الاوبئه مثل الكوليرا يمكن ان تنتشر
في المدن مثل الخرطوم
فمنهم جدا للسلطات والاطراف المقاتله ان
تضمن
استمرار عملي محطات المياه وكافه البنى
التحتيه المزوده للمياه والكهرباء ان تكون
محميه وان
تعمل وان يتمكن كافه الموظفين من الذهاب
الى اعمالهم بامان لانهم اذا لم يقموا
بعملياتها الصيانه على البنى التحتيه
الخاصه الكهرباء
بالتاكيد ستكون اوضاع مزريه بالنسبه الى
القطاع الصيدلي سيد
جريمه الصيدليات مقفله
الصيدليات ليس بوسيها ان تعمل بالوضع
الطبيعي لانهم بحاجه الى الادويه
من المزودين
فكل شيء فيما يخص حركه
المنتجات والبشر في الخرطوم لا يعمل بشكل
طبيعي هذا هو الوضع بشكل اساسي من كسل جري
من مدير الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات